good morning and welcome everybody to
this uh licensing subcommittee which has
been convened to determine an
application for premises licensed
variation in respect of the aldi store
at girling street sudbury
in accordance with the the hearing
regulations applicants and parties
making a representation
to the application
have a right to attend
hearings determining those applications
and accordingly you'll be running in
accordance with that
um
the the procedure will we'll start with
some preliminary housekeeping and agenda
items we need to be dealt with um then
there'll be some pre-hearing
introductions and a couple of
formalities to deal with that
once the hearing proper starts um it
will take the following format firstly
there will be a report from the the
licensing officer who will outline the
application
then the applicant will be asked to
present the case for the application
to the subcommittee
followed by any other person that made
representations in respect
of the application uh there may be
questions asked
for each of the uh the presentations
made um but just a reminder that the the
questions are should be in relation to
the the presentations and for seeking
clarification etcetera
um
once all parties have made their
representations
uh the there may be some summing up by
the the licensing officer is required
and the the applicant will have the the
final summing up there may be some some
final questions from the members just to
to clarify um any issues
the subcommittee will then go into
private session to determine the
application and as quickly as they can
they will return to the open meeting to
to make the decision um so firstly
actually we'll go over to um councillor
margaret mabry who is the the chair of
the licensing and regulatory full
committee so he's going to chair this
subcommittee today over to you
councillor
uh thank you very much mr dulu uh yes my
name's margaret mabry and i am chairman
of the licensing and regulatory
committee at baby district council
welcome to this virtual meeting of the
licensing subcommittee
i would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to youtube and will be capable of
repeated viewing the meeting will be
recorded except where there are
confidential or exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you'll be deemed by the council
to have consented to be recorded by
entering this meeting as a speaker you
are also consenting to be recorded by
the council and to the possible use of
those sound recordings for webcasting
and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press
may record film photograph or broadcast
this meeting when the public and the
press are not lawfully excluded
please ensure that microphones are muted
when you are not speaking
that you do not interrupt other speakers
that if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave
additionally you will be invited to
speak and ask questions by the chair me
please await your turn
thank
you i am now going to um move on to the
agenda and item three is apologies for
absence
thank you chair we've received apologies
this morning from councillor ayers thank
you very much and we have a substitute
would you like to introduce yourself
please
counselor none
counselor john dunn
thank you very thank you very much
item four is declarations of interest by
councillors are there any declarations
of interest please no chairman
uh councillor nan
no
thank you um uh none none from me either
thank you
um
i am now going to
conduct the introduction so everyone is
aware of who everyone is as i said my
name's margaret mabry and i'm the
chairman of
this
the licensing and regulatory committee
um and now i'll ask
my other colleagues to introduce
themselves
morning i'm councillor sue carpendale
and i'm the vice chairman of the
licensing and regulatory committee
thank you
good morning i'm councillor john nunn
representing the long melford ward and
member of the licensing regulatory
committee
thank you very much and now i'm going to
ask the officers in attendance to
introduce themselves and i'll begin with
mr dulu please
hello yes i'm nigel dulu i'm the legal
business partner for the council and i'm
legal advisor to this subcommittee
thank you
my name's catherine greene and i'm the
licensing officer for baber mid suffolk
thank you
good morning i'm kerry chandler and the
licensing officer for weber mid-suffolk
thank you
good morning karen sayer governance
officer
thank you very much
bethany webb trainee governance officer
thank you very much
and we also have um alicia norman who is
in the background and she is in charge
of the i.t and the live streaming
if you see the name that is who it is so
thank you very much
um i'm now going to ask the applicant to
introduce themselves please or if they
are represented as a representative to
make the introductions please
hello my name is lisa gilligan and i
represent aldi stores limited for this
application
thank you very much and i also ask you
um
miss gilligan
have you
have you received the procedure report
and copies of the relevant notice
yes thank you very much thank you thank
you very much
um and other persons who are present um
we have mr finnegan would you like to
introduce yourself please
yes thank you chair um my name is david
finnegan and i live adjacent to the ld
store
thank you very thank you very much are
there any other members of the public
presence that i haven't asked a bit to
introduce themselves i don't think say
no
um i'm now going to ask whether either
party
either of you
are do you wish to withdraw the
application or the representation
miss gilligan
no i don't wish to withdraw it we have
an amendment to it which i can make
during my submission but not to withdraw
okay thank you very much mr finnegan no
i don't wish
thank you very much thank you
um and my question to the licensing
officer or questions is have there been
any requests from the parties for
permission to call witnesses please
no chair thank you and have the parties
indicated they wish to
present documentary or other material
no jam
um miss gilligan has already declared
that she has an amendment which mr dulu
are you happy that we um
we hear this in the next part in part
five
yes that can be done during the
presentation that's fine thank you very
much thank you
i'm going to now ask the applicant um to
estimate the time required to present
the case to the committee please could i
just double check the time required make
sure i don't go over
is there a is there a limit
no we don't have a limit right okay and
if some people do a reasonable amount of
time no no no you get clocks and they
count down and so i thought you better
just double check
thank you very much thank you very much
members of the committee um just by way
of background this application was
originally submitted on behalf of aldi
miss gilligan i'm just asking if you
have
an estimate of the time we haven't quite
stopped
oh gosh five minutes
okay not long thank you no no i'll be as
brief as possible obviously happy to
take questions but i'll be there
too it's just a general
just a general timing thank you and i
asked the same question of mr finnegan
yes there should be a couple of moments
um
what i've got to say thank you
thank you very much thank you and now we
move on to item five of the agenda which
is the hearing and i'm going to ask the
licensing officer catherine to present
her report which is b stroke l a sub
stroke 21 stroke 2
and i'll hand over to catherine please
and thank you
thank you chair
this hearing is to determine an
application made to vary the premises
license made under section 34 of the
licensing act 2003 for audi stores
limited in relation to the premises of
aldi girling street sudbury suffolk
the application was received by the
licensing authority on the 27th of
october 2021 and a copy of this is
attached to this report as appendix b
the application made has been subject to
the statutory consultation period as
prescribed by regulation
the notices advertising the application
have been on display at the premises and
published in the press
the main element of the variation seeks
to alter the existing premises license
by extending authorized hours for the
sale of alcohol and opening hours to
commence from 600 hours and end at
midnight excuse me midnight monday to
sunday
aldi sudbury has benefited from a
premises license issued by baba district
council since the 7th of november 2005
and prior to that from a magistrate's
liquor license under the 1964 licensing
act
a summary of the current premises
license is attached to this report as
appendix a a hearing is necessary to
determine the application following
receipt of a relevant representation
which has not been withdrawn
the licensing authority must carry out
its functions under the act with a view
to promoting the licensing objectives
which are the prevention of crime and
disorder public safety the prevention of
public nuisance and the protection of
children from harm
in carrying out its licensing functions
the licensing authority must have regard
to its statement of licensing policy
published under section 5 of the act and
any guidance issued by the secretary of
state under section 182
where revisions are made to the
legislation or guidance issued by the
secretary of state there may be a period
of time when the local statement of
licensing policy is inconsistent with
these revisions
in these circumstances the licensing
authority will have regard and give
appropriate weight to the relevant
changes guidance and also its own
statement of licensing policy
the subcommittee will also be aware of
the human rights act 1998 considerations
specifically article 6 for the applicant
and articles 8 and 1 of protocol 1 for
those raising representations
when determining applications for the
grant
of a variation license the subcommittee
must having regard the representations
made take such of the steps if any it
considers appropriate for the promotion
of the licensing objectives
to grant
the
variations subject to conditions which
are consistent with the operating
schedule accompanying the application
modified to such a as extent as the
authority considers appropriate
promotion of the licensing objectives
and subject to any mandatory conditions
which must be included in the license
or to reject the whole or part of the
application for these purposes
conditions of the license are modified
if any of them are altered or omitted or
any new condition is added
any party agreed by this decision taken
by the licensing authority in respect to
this application as a statutory right of
appeal to the magistrate's court and
that concludes my
submission chair
thank you thank you very much catherine
for that
um i now ask um
the parties present here if they have
any questions for the licensing of
officer and i start with the applicant
ms gilligan
do you have any questions for the
licensing officer please no thank you
chair
thank you very much and mr finnegan do
you have any questions for the licensing
officer please
thank you cheer
thank you very much um and now i'll ask
my colleagues on the subcommittee and
councillor carpendale do you have any
questions for the officer please
we can't hear you counsellor
sorry
thank you
got some problems this morning um no no
no questions at this stage thank you
chair thank you uh councillor nun do you
have any questions for the officer
none at this time
thank you very much thank you
thank you
i now ask
the applicant and then
which will be miss gilligan
to present the case
thank you very much miss gilligan the
floor is yours as they say
thank you very much
um apologies i tried to go a little
earlier and as i was um said a few
moments ago just by way of background
and this application is one of a program
of 400 applications submitted nationwide
these are for aldi stores which are
essentially the oldest stores in the
estate which have current premises
licenses which run 8 until 11.
over the past 12 to 18 months this store
as a number of others has opened at 7 00
a.m either by virtue of temporary event
notices or to achieve social distancing
which is the motivation for this trench
of applications now um four applications
and obviously having read the
representations on page 35 and 36 i just
want to say from the outset that aldi
are content to amend this application
from
six until midnight to seven until eleven
which essentially leaves the terminal
hour as it is on the current premises
license which your senior report
currently runs
eight until 11 monday to saturday oh
baby pardon 10 until 10 30 on sundays
we're content to leave the terminal
hours as is
but seeking um a seven o'clock start
time
simply to achieve to be able to
avoid the need for temporary event
notices moving forward and to be able to
achieve social distancing the business
genuinely hoped that social distancing
wouldn't be necessary again but i think
as the last 12 months and currents
current circumstances illustrate
we can never say never again
there isn't there is no intention for
these premises to suddenly start and
there was never an intention to open and
trade six until midnight it was
genuinely just to achieve maximum
operational flexibility obviously
wouldn't wish to diminish from the
representations and concerns that have
obviously been raised by residents so
hence the the amendment so we're
essentially just seeking now um an
amendment to the start time um to um 7
a.m
and again it isn't that aldi want to
permanently change trading hours and
start opening all their 900 stores at
7am but without the variation it can
only be done with temporary event
notices and you and your colleagues will
be aware of the time limits that those
you know that are imposed um with that
application process
for the um sake of complete transparency
as well i would say we do have temporary
event notice for next week this store
will open at seven for christmas week
monday the 20th to christmas eve
um and then yeah and so i you know i
just wanted to sort of you know to make
that clear but this application really
is to achieve
operational flexibility moving forward
so that um you know should social
distancing or you know a seasonal time
such as christmas should a seven o'clock
opening be required it can be done
without the need for further
applications
and i would say in terms of the
temporary event notices there were
obviously no representations at all from
police or eho
so i think i hope that gives you the
background to the application the
reasoning why but having read the
representations you know
happy to make that um compromise
suggestion
um thank you thank you very much miss
miss gilligan i'm just going to ask mr
dulu before i um proceed further mr de
lou are you happy for that amendment to
be put forward
yes that that's perfectly the the
applicant's discretion to make that
amendment
thank you thank you very much um i now
ask um mr finnegan if he has any
any questions or
for miss gilligan
yes thank you
thank you for that uh mr gilligan i
appreciate the attempt to compromise
there
i do understand but
the the concern still remains the amount
of movement and disruption
the later part of the day especially
is quite detrimental to the sleep
patterns etc etc now the the way the the
car park entrance is when cars come in
the headlights
beam right up into the bedroom
um and so mr gilligan do you have any
actual questions you you'll be
you'll be giving your submissions
shortly but do you have any actual
questions for miss gilligan at this time
uh no questions at this time thank you
it's mr finnigan by the way
thank you thank you very much thank you
mr finnegan
um
i'm now going to ask the subcommittee if
they have any questions for miss
gilligan um
councillor carpenter please thank you
chair um good morning miss gillian
can i just uh have you confirm exactly
what you're proposing
um in all cases no start before 7 a.m
yes
and in all cases finish by
uh 2300 hours yes we're not seeking to
amend the terminal hour at all on the
existing license so what we'll be
seeking and given i'm trying to give as
much assurance as i can given the sunday
trading restrictions i'm content for
sunday to remain as is
so that would be 10 until 22 30
and then on mondays to saturdays we'd be
seeking 0 700 to 23
100 hours at the moment the license is
oh 800 to 2300 hours so in terms of the
end of the day we're not looking to
change anything we're not we've you know
we're not looking to change the license
at all it is one additional hour
07 to 08 monday to saturday morning okay
and obviously because of the sunday
trading restrictions you're just looking
for flexibility within that six-hour
time slot
well
at the moment the current premises
license says 10 to 10 30. yeah but
because of sunday trading you know we
it's up to you know as with everybody
ever you know a similar size we're we're
bound by those restrictions or you know
that that's the trump card already so
you know i'm we're content to leave our
license on sunday as is and as i say
it's just that additional hour monday to
saturday monday to saturday okay thank
you that's that's helpful thank you
thank you very much uh councillor nunn
do you have a question
um just a point of a note really um i've
just noticed that uh mr mr uh finnegan
um lives with
a an old friend of mine
um
does the applicant have any objections
to that
um
no i i trust your judgment counsellor
none thank you very much no
thank you i thought i just better not
mention that thank you mr dulu are you
happy for that um declaration
um yes as long as some councillor none
can assure everybody that he will make
his determination purely on the facts of
the
application before him and uh in
consideration of the licensing
objectives
absolutely yes
thank you mr finnegan i'm going to ask
you
let me see i don't know mr nun and uh i
was unaware of this relationship so um i
just wanted to put on the record as well
for miss gilligan's uh information thank
you thank you thank you david that's
that is very that's very kind of you mr
mr finnegan and so we will um
go
go forward so there were no questions
for the applicant councillor none
no
no and um my question has already been
answered too
um so
i have no questions either thank you
very much
um mr finnegan um it's now
your there is now your opportunity to
present your case if you would like to
carry on and thank you yes thank you
very much chair uh yeah just as as i was
speaking earlier on about um the traffic
coming into the car park and the lights
that shine through right directly
through the bedroom window that i sleep
in
um that's a cause of disruption the
noise levels are going to be quite
disruptive as well people potentially
wheeling charlie's about later on in the
evening than they are at the moment i
appreciate the licenses for 11 o'clock
as it stands
but that extra hour makes a big
difference in terms of the sleep i don't
keep very well
and
obviously
sleep is important to me
and obviously everybody else in the
house
and it's very difficult um when you've
got lorries coming i appreciate miss
gilligan and said that um
the store will only be open between the
hours uh
seven and eleven
but deliveries delivery lawyers have um
come
to deliver products to the store
out with these hours quite often
quite often they're a lot earlier than
seven o'clock in the morning it can be
between five and six in the morning as
well
and i'm worried that that will be the
case later on in the evening as well
especially if covert restrictions do
become um more of a problem for
everybody it might be difficult again
with drivers etc they may be delivering
out with the normal times i appreciate
the need for flexibility on this issue
um but i think that's also a problem
because these lorries are refrigerated
lorries and they make a hell of a racket
whilst they're sitting delivering their
products
um i just thought i'd bring that into
the the
scenario
um
as a as you have seen from the what i
sent into the
committee
um he's concerned about the law he's
concerned about the noise and the lights
etc concerned about the movement in the
the car park
also concerned that should there be a
further lockdown and
license premises
have to close at some point
then
obviously then that will encourage
people to go to supermarkets to get get
their alcohol
um and this might be also a problem
um so i'm just bringing these issues
other than that
a regular user of the store and
appreciate this door but
but concerned about these issues if you
could consider them thank you very much
you're on moot chair sorry
thank you thank you very much
and there was a noise outside so i went
on mute but thank you mr finnegan very
much thank you
i'm now going to ask um
miss gilligan if she has any question
for mr finnegan
none at all thank you i now ask my
subcommittee if they have any questions
um councillor carpendale please um thank
you chair uh good morning mr finnegan um
it sounds as if you you are concerned
about the issues as they exist
at the moment um you'll have heard that
the applicant is is basically saying to
change the the license by one hour in
the morning
um i think if we if we ask the applicant
in a moment
if that will impact on deliveries or not
that that might
allay some of your concerns um
does that sound fair because the the
evening closures are not actually going
to change
i do i do have sympathy for what you're
saying because i tend to i live quite
close to the supermarket in my village
and i do understand what you mean about
headlights coming into the bedroom
window at night
um i'm afraid it's just just one of
those things
but um
is it just the morning hour that
concerns you and the possible
change to delivery lorries
the morning and the evening because it
currently closes at 10 at 10 p.m sorry
in the evening
and if they remain open i appreciate the
license
in terms of the licenses up until 11
o'clock but in terms of the disruption
that's going to continue for an
additional hour so it's about opening us
rather than the licensing changing
um
pretty much yeah the f well that the
fact that the the alcohol license and
the implications thereafter as i
mentioned with regards to possible
effects of covet etc that could be
problematic in terms of the amount of
use and disruption that's going to be
caused okay all right thank you mr
finnegan
is that the only question councillor yes
it is thank you councillor nunn do you
have a question for mr [ __ ]
uh councillor carpenter basically asked
the question i was just gonna ask anyway
so at this point no
thank you very much mr finnegan um i do
have a question please if you wouldn't
mind answering um could i ask you is it
the noise or is it the light
pollution that affects you mostly
it's both actually they're both equally
as um problematic unfortunately
as i said with the delivery lorries in
particular that as i said the
refrigeration units on them will make
quite a racket
i understand that people need to get the
food and that needs to come to the store
etc but
um
if it's
going to be extended it's going to be
really quite upsetting in terms of my
health
and obviously everybody else is in the
house
thank you very much um
i'm going to go to councillor carpenter
first and then i'm going to come back to
miss gilligan thank you thank you chair
i i was just wondering if
some of our questions in fact are
straying away from licensing and maybe
into planning or or other zones that
maybe uh mr dulu can advise
i'll i'll assist with the summoning up
before we go into private session i'll
make a couple of comments in respect to
that if that's okay
thank you very much thank you very much
um miss gilligan thank you
all i was going to ask and perhaps um a
caution against inviting this question
but i just wondered mr finnegan whether
you'd ever raised any complaints with
the council's environmental health
officers about you know about
the district the disruption you
you've commented on
i i haven't personally because i've not
been long living at the premises
um i noticed the the signage going up
and i was concerned by the
i mean it's already quite noisy at times
when they deliver especially it's early
in the morning or late at night
um so um that's basically coming from
this is a licensing issue and as as i
say don't
object so much about the factor to sell
on alcohol other than the fact it's
going to encourage more people to use
the store um at these later and earlier
hours yes thank you thank you very much
mr finnegan and um miss gilligan thank
you
thank you indeed um before and mr dulu
actually um states this
um i will actually explain that we are
looking at the alcohol license rather
than any other
planning issue but thank you
thank you if there are no more questions
i'm going to move on to the closing
submissions no more questions from
anyone at the moment
no thank you very much
i'm going to ask the licensing officer
catherine to give a closing statement
please and to summarise any points which
need clarity thank you
thank you chair i did just have a
question of miss gilligan if i may um
with regards to the changing in timings
is that applicable for both the opening
hours and the alcohol sales
yeah perfect thank you yes um i i have
okay thank you um i have no other
closing submission statements to make
chair thank you thank you thank you very
much um i now ask um the same of the of
the applicant
if you would like to give a closing
submission please ms gilligan
thank you thank you i will be as brief
as possible i i just for the avoidance
of any doubt that there isn't an
intention to change the end of the
operating day for aldi there is
currently a license which goes monday
through saturday until 11. the the store
does currently close
generally at 10 o'clock as i'm sure mr
finnegan will will confirm what we're
looking at is the morning and just i
think it was i think it was maybe uh
councillor carbondale that touched on
this
this additional hour will make no
difference at all in terms of our
delivery um
runs delivery times et cetera it is not
going to impact or cause a greater
thoroughfare traffic of delivery times
and then
and and it is also at this stage not
intended that this will be a permanent
alteration that starts tomorrow and runs
forever it is for operational
flexibility
now i think all i would say in a more
general licensing term as you and your
colleagues will be well aware this isn't
a once and for all that the licensing
system has a review process built in
there and if complaints are made by mr
finigor finnegan or indeed anyone else
which we founded with evidence linked to
our store this matter could obviously i
sincerely hope i don't come back before
you but this matter could be put back
before you for you know for you to make
a decision based on evidence linked to
our store but at the moment
all we are seeking is an additional hour
to the license monday to saturday um
in the absence of any um complaints you
know or or adverse comments from any of
you or any of the responsible
authorities
thank you thank you very much thank you
i now move on
to
item six which is the exclusion of the
public
um i'm just going to check that all
parties have had sufficient time to put
forward their case are you all quite
happy at the moment with that thank you
very much
and i have to
read this motion to you so biologist
chair just before we go into the private
section uh there's just a couple of
things i think i should say sort of
while this is still open
yes please
okay
first of all the
the store will always be
subject to the sunday trading hours
um the sunday trading act um from 1994
which restricts opening times for stores
that are over 280 square meters in
retail space which
i'm sure
this store is um there's also the the
christmas day opening act which they
will also have to comply with as well
which generally prevents opening on
christmas day there are
exceptions in in the schedule of that
act
just to raise that first and secondly
just to remind that we are considering
just the application with regards to the
alcohol sales there is nothing stopping
aldi
opening any hours they wish to
you know provided them in compliance
with those those two acts and also
whether there are any planning
conditions um attached to the property
which i'm not aware of um so that there
is actually nothing stopping the store
opening
for longer hours
obviously they will not be entitled to
sell alcohol for all those hours but you
often see in stores where shutters are
pulled down in front of alcohol areas
and anyway so
what i'm trying to say is that what you
need to consider is the impact
that the extra hour of the alcohol
license will have
on the licensing objectives and we're
looking
really only at the the uh the public
nuisance
um objective i don't think any issues
have been raised with regard to crime
protection children harm or public
safety it is really the the public
nuisance aspect
so you need to look at it in the context
of a a general store which is entitled
to sell all sorts of groceries and
knowing ld all sorts of other bits and
pieces as well um so i just wanted this
would be something i would normally say
in private session but there's no reason
for me not to give you this advice um
openly um before you go in to make the
decision
uh thank you very much dulu and and i
hope that that was transparent for both
um
both parties here so thank you
um
i will now read the motion
on the basis that the subcommittee
considers that the public interest in
excluding the public outweighs the
public interest in its deliberation
being held in public
it is resolved that
under section 100 a in brackets 4 of the
local government act 1972 the public
will be excluded from the meeting for
item 13 on the grounds that it involves
the likely disc disclosure of exempt
information as defined in part one of
schedule 12 of the act
on the ground set out in regulation 14
in brackets 2 of the licensing act 2003
in brackets hearings regulations
2005.
and i require a second
second
uh thank you councillor carpenter has
seconded um the notion um what will
happen now for the benefit especially of
mr finnegan if you're not aware we will
now go into private session the live
streaming will be stopped when we have
made a decision we will be back with you
and also miss gilligan i'm sure you're
very aware that and that was for you as
well so thank you very much
thank you
chair can we just check with
thank you very much and now hand back to
uh mr dulu as we
as the subcommittee have returned thank
you
thank you chair uh
the
subcommittee have considered all the
representations made before them today
um in accordance with all the relevant
guidance um and having considered that
they are satisfied that the the extra
hour opening and for the alcohol sales
on the the in the mornings from 7 a.m
will have little or no material
difference to the operation of the store
and the granting of the extension is
unlikely to contribute to any adverse
impact
of any of the licensing objectives and
therefore have decided to grant the
application as amended by the applicant
this morning
as mentioned in the licensing officers
report earlier there is a statutory
right of appeal for any party who has
made an application of representations
who is agreed by the decision or the
imposition of any condition and that
application should be made to the
magistrates court within 21 days of
receiving a written notification of the
decision
thank you chair back to you
uh thank you mr dulu and just to confirm
that the hours will be
mr dulu
to confirm the hours
okay yes um they are from 7 00 a.m till
11 p.m um and my understanding that is
the the licensing is for seven days a
week although as mentioned earlier they
will be subject to licensing sunday
trading regulations thank you very much
that's just to make it clear for
absolutely everyone um i do have a few
comments as chairman that i would like
to make
and it is obvious from this hearing this
morning that there are some existing
issues between
aldi and the residents
and we would encourage
some forms of communication between the
parties to resolve
this issue
if these issues
are not satisfactorily resolved
obviously there is always the
opportunity for the residents to
um resort to the council's environmental
department
i would also like to comment um
we cannot request and we cannot
recommend but i would suggest that
perhaps oldie would like to consider
installing some form
of acoustic material
to the fencing of the neighboring
properties and perhaps also
consider
some
blackout
blinds for those properties to help with
their relationships
as i've stated we cannot request we
cannot recommend but we would suggest
that perhaps aldi would like to
open communications with the parties
concerned
and thank you
thank you very much
it's i now close this meeting i thank
everyone present for being here officers
subcommittee and the members of the
public miss gilligan and mr finnegan
thank you so much for attending uh the
meeting is now ending at 10 52.
says um just commenting on your comments
i don't think we have any contact
details for mr finnegan and the letter
was as i understand it the rep it just
it was signed mr so if if mr feling is
happy to give an email perhaps to a
licensing officer officers either either
or it can be passed on then i can you
know pass that you know i can pass that
on to the appropriate area manager you
know for dialogue to to open thanks
thank you very much um that's very
positive mr finnegan you wanted to say
something but you're on mute
before you try
but you'll get caught out thank you
just to say i'm happy for that
information to be passed on
by a member of the council team if
they're happy to do so
thank you um catherine i'm just going to
bring you in here catherine did you hear
that confirmation please
i i did yester thank you very much thank
you so there will be some communication
between the two parties and thank you
very much so i do now end the meeting
and
if i may i would like to wish everyone a
very happy christmas thank you
you